welcome to conversion optimization
foundations i'm brian eisenberg the new
york times bestselling author of waiting
for your cut to bark always be testing
and call to action
i'm here to talk to you a lot about
conversion optimization see
i'm not one of the smartest guys in the
world i'm not one of the most creative
marketers in the world however over the
years i've received numerous accolades
from being considered one of the top 10
user experience gurus in the world to
being a 40 on the 40 marketer and what
it is is just taking the same effort
you're doing currently but just working
at them a little harder and i'll explain
to what that means
let's imagine you have two different
websites they both have ten thousand
visitors in a year at the end of the
year you've converted two percent of
them
that means you end up with 200 customers
200 orders but 9 800 of those customers
never decided to purchase from you the
following year site 1 stays exactly the
same but site 2 started working on the
principles conversion optimization that
you're going to learn in the series
what they've been able to do is increase
their conversion rate by about five
percent every month so at the end of the
year they've increased their conversion
rate by 50 percent that means at the end
of that year they're going to have close
to 300 orders again a 50 increase in
sales not because they drove in more
traffic through seo or ppc not because
they've increased their level of
engagement in content marketing or
social media not because they've sent
out more emails they've done exactly the
same efforts all they've done is taken
the time to understand their customers
do maybe a little bit of a b testing
some usability testing
and just improve the creative and the
customer experience to get huge gains
now you're going to learn things such as
the conversion trinity
this is a very simple principle that
i've developed that you can go ahead and
apply it and i'll help you identify what
you can do to improve your ads as well
as your copy we're going to learn
principles such as scent scent is
something that was first discovered in
1995 it's one of the most fundamental
principles of online experiences yet
it's one of the most underutilized thing
by most markers the user experience
world knows about it it's time you did
we're going to learn things about how to
a b test and there's so many things that
you can do with testing let me just give
you a couple of examples
you may be fortunate enough to find an
incredible graphic that you can change
on one place on one website that
increases the conversion rate and
gives you a benefit of over 25 million
dollars annually i did that for
overstock.com or maybe you visited a
dell website one point and you'll notice
that in the configurator they used to
have to stand their language and we help
them change that language to the words
help me choose before you pick the
option
that has accounted for tens of millions
of dollars over the years or we've
worked with tons of smaller business
where we've changed the headline or
we've changed the unique value
proposition and increased the conversion
rate by 81 percent
or we've gone in and improved ads that
have gone and improved ultimate results
the thing is these small efforts these
small changes can have huge impact as
long as you keep applying over and over
again over time right this incremental
change that's what conversion
optimization is about it's about using
the exact same techniques that you've
been doing but just improving them
taking a second guess because not always
do we have to be 100 right we can find
ways to improve what we're doing
i look forward to teaching you the rest
of this course and seeing your massive
successes with conversion optimization
thank you